what would you tell to twenty-year-old
directors just getting started or they
don't have to be 20 they could be
younger I got it
stop making stuff you have an iPhone in
your pocket it's perfectly good
just stop practicing your craft but
figure out what really turns you on you
know and just be yourself maybe you do
things in an unconventional way and some
people might think that's a weakness but
actually that can become a strength like
I realized at film school certain kinds
of movies that I love to watch I wasn't
very good at making you know just
because I love paul thomas anderson
doesn't mean i could make a film like
him you know you can get really enamored
with these giants of hollywood and think
well i got to make something like my
hero and then I kind of realized well
actually the weirder things about my
sensibility that I used to think we're a
weakness on my strengths that's what
makes me original that's my voice and
the stronger and more unique your voices
actually the more commercial your work
will be right because it's pure and it
touches people so just try and find your
voice and you can do that for no money
you can do that with your iPhone just
keep making things keep pushing and you
will get there you will get there I find
that interesting so yeah just because
you love certain style don't try to
emulate it because it may not be kind of
you know like we all go through a thing
where we fall in love with Hitchcock or
whoever Ross Scorsese these incredible
people and then you look at what you're
making and you can be so dispirited
because of course it's not as good as
Hitchcock or Scorsese and realistically
it probably never will be but that's
okay don't try and be them try and be
you and I probably intellectually knew
that but as time has gone on I really
feel that I feel that in my stomach that
I've just got to be me and actually my
unique weird whatever take on things is
good enough and actually it's a lot
better than if I'm trying to copy
filmmakers
that I admire but that just comes with
experience you know so looking back on
everything now why are you still working
in the film industry cool I just I mean
I just love it I don't know what else to
tell you it's a cliche but it just it
lights me up it's there's nothing that
satisfies me more and you know I just
showed the film in Brooklyn like a
couple of days ago and hearing the
audience gasp in shock or laughs or you
know have whatever emotional reaction
they had it really does make it all
worthwhile
because you do this because you're
trying to connect with others I mean
that's the word that underscores the
soul
weirdly you go into a very isolated
space and you're working on it for a few
years and you're in an edit room or
you're writing and a lot of moments of
being alone and isolated but it's that
communal atmosphere that you're always
thinking about and how is this going to
play for an audience and when you get
the joy of that happening and it works
it really makes all the ups and downs
worthwhile and that's why I do it you
know because that's what inspired me
when filmmakers gave me that good
feeling of joy in my heart and I hope to
be able to keep doing that for the rest
of my life it's the only thing I want to
do whenever I go into a movie theater
and there's no one there I'm like I hope
at least one person I don't want to be
the only one here even if it's just one
person and it doesn't have to be a movie
theater it could be somebody watching it
on a streaming platform but you know if
you can get across that thing that was
in your head to that person that's cool
it's super hard but the challenge is
part of what makes it worthwhile so I
don't know what to tell you I just
irrationally totally love it with all my
heart despite how hard it is maybe
because of how hard it is and I think
I'll keep doing it till the day I die
what are the stories you want to tell
and be involved in well you know
honestly I just want to entertain people
I just want people to walk out of films
that I am acting in or directing feeling
like they're walking on air maybe I've
taken them to a really dark place but
that they feel more alive by the end of
it
so actually you know I just want to give
people joy I think that's really what
it's all about for me and if you can
inspire you know discussion about tough
issues or controversial issues or maybe
issues that are quite unresolved in
society that's great
but number one entertain people you know
and even if that's all you do that's
enough that's really enough to give
people joy is a pretty amazing thing so
I want to be a part of productions that
do that
did you see the room I did see the room
I saw the room and paulin with Tommy
Weiser oh you did and you know what
fine it's kind of a masterpiece uh-huh I
mean okay is it a zero star movie or a
five star movie well you could argue
that's a five star movie I mean because
of the audience engagement and the joy
if that's your pure metric it's one of
the best movies I've ever seen and
people throwing right at the screen and
and the line right I mean you know and
again like I said professional wrestling
people think that's very uncool but it
brings tears to my eyes it gives me joy
that's awesome you know that's that's
you feel alive when you when you got
that smile on your face yeah that's
really cool he was in the audience he
came and did a Q&A it was so cool it was
really great why do you ask about that I
was just thinking of the one scene in
the one with James Franco where just you
see him pull up in a limo you know and
it's it's just that that night of like
the first screening for all filmmakers
yeah and there's so many emotions but
it's like this stamp of okay I did it
right and now people are coming to see
it and sometimes it's a bigger deal than
it really is and sometimes it's the
opposite totally but you don't know that
going into it totally and so that seemed
and then he drives around again you know
and it's and it's funny and especially
if you've ever had your first screening
and you just kind of know how like it's
such a huge deal but then anxious as
hell I mean right you can't not be right
right so yeah I don't know why I just
that popped into my head when you were
talking and I just picked
Tommy Wiseau the real Tommy Wiseau in
the limo or those harde the James Franco
version yes and you know going around
softer oh yeah oh my god yes yes the
only thing I could really add is like
you never quite know what's going to
connect with people I'm not sure if I
even have an answer
to say about this but it's like you just
kind of keep making stuff and it can
surprise you what does hit it might not
be the thing that you expect but if you
just keep making stuff I didn't really
have a formula on so it's just thing
I've noticed do you know right yeah
anyway you know not sure what I would
say about it like you never know how an
audience is going to respond but you
just have to be connected to keeping on
telling stories and then eventually
could do it there'll be something that
sort of seems to land
all right maybe that's why there's no
answers because we never know I mean to
have this viral video right oh that's it
onto my lap and then it's like okay wow
that open all these doors and yeah sure
yeah you just don't know but if you keep
making the effort and putting yourself
out there it's more likely you're gonna
find something that will connect you
know that's really all you can control
did Tommy do a QA he did he did anything
interesting he said oh my god well he
was loving the whole thing and I just
Rose it's a pretty good business model I
mean he's selling t-shirts and selling
posters and I was like this guy's really
this is a profitable movie now this is a
super profitable movie so he kind of
owns that he was playing a character
right I mean I'm playing Tommy mm-hm but
he's very smart for doing that right and
he does it well yeah it was cool I
really enjoyed that and the disaster
artist was a really good movie - I
thought it was very funny but then
there's also parts that are very true to
anybody who's ever trying to make a film
completely frightening ly true yeah
you